die zahl der toten der flutkatastrophe
steigt weiter und viele menschen werden
noch immer vermisst
die korona zahlen in den niederlanden
nehmen rasant zu es wächst die sorge
dass die welle nach deutschland schwappt
und nach einem rassistischen vorfall
brechen deutschlands olympia fußballer
ein testspiel gegen honduras
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu unserem
nachrichtenüberblick norbert lehmann es
auch wieder dabei für den sport genannt
in den katastrophengebieten finden die
einsatzkräfte immer wieder leichen die
zahl der todesopfer liegt mittlerweile
bei 141
hunderte menschen sind verletzt immer
noch werden viele vermisst ihr schicksal
zerreißt unser herz sagte der
bundespräsident als er sich heute ein
bild machte in erftstadt nordrhein
westfalen in dem ort wenige kilometer
südlich von köln ist es besonders
dramatisch erdrutsche haben ganze häuser
weggerissen nicht auszuschließen dass in
den schlammmassen noch punkte liegen
so sah der ortsteil erftstadt blessem
einmal von oben aus und so ist die
anlage jetzt nach der verheerenden flut
barbara lueg berichtet so still so
beklemmend diese bilder heute sind
westlich von köln in nordrhein westfalen
die straße bei erftstadt bliesheim ist
überflutet und mit ihr zahllose autos
die vom wasser überrascht wurden
wir haben dort 28 bestätigte fahrzeuge
die unter wasser lagen teilweise in
wassertiefen bis zu zwölf metern
akribisch kontrollieren taucher und
bundeswehr jedes auto um sicherzustellen
dass niemand im wagen zurück geblieben
ist gott sei dank bis zum nachmittag
werden keine toten gemeldet ein wunder
und die pegelstände bleiben stabil auch
ein stück weiter leichte entwarnung dort
wo gestern ein erdrutsch zahllose häuser
mit sich riss und den kompletten ortrand
in eine sandgrube spülte gegen mittag
machen sich hier ministerpräsident
laschet und bundespräsident steinmeier
ein bild der lage
appell an alle in der not steht unser
land zusammen ich jeder kann seinen teil
dazu beitragen dass ein wenig von der
not der menschen hier in den betroffenen
regionen gelindert wird
der politik aber traut norbert richert
nicht über den weg
stinksauer kehrt er heute in sein haus
in erftstadt zurück und macht seinem
ärger luft was soll nur werden leute
gestorben leute haben ihr haus ihre
existenz es gibt viele leute die sind
nicht elementar versichert wie soll das
gehen
wie soll das gehen und dann nur sich vor
die kamera zu stellen und zu sagen wir
helfen und dann ist stelle ich mir die
frage wann und wie
und so stehen sie heute da in erftstadt
auf der straße sitzen ratlos auf dem was
übrig ist und tunken ihre häuser leer
frage an dort pfarrer vor ort hat
erftstadt das schlimmste überstanden nun
zumindest geht das wasser zurück und es
kommt auch keines mehr von oben und die
bergung der personen ist weit
vorangeschritten
die haben es gehört hier
glücklicherweise auf der straße in den
autos da waren niemand
es gibt aber noch bereiche die kritisch
sind das ist vor allem die kiesgrube 500
meter von hier entfernt dort können
keine rettungskräfte heben weil weiter
eine akute abrutsch gefahr besteht dort
wird mit drohnen das gebiet überwacht
also da weiß man nicht was dort noch
kommt und ein weiterer sensibler punkt
ist die steinbachtalsperre unweit von
hier dort hat die bezirksregierung köln
am nachmittag gesagt dass bestehe weiter
akute gefahr denn der damen der ist
total brüchig von den wassermassen man
pumpt dort jetzt ab aber erst wenn zwei
drittel ab gebunden sind kann entwarnung
gegeben werden
das wird wohl morgen nachmittag seien
also insoweit das bestehen wir auch noch
risiken
danke schön dort der stadt gehen wir 60
kilometer weiter nordwestlich in den
kreis heinsberg an der niederländischen
grenze
dort hatten die menschen eine
aufwühlende nacht im kleinen ort abrufen
hatten sie so gehofft dass der damm an
der ruhr hält doch er brach die rund 700
einwohner mussten raus aus ihren häusern
brigitte sauer ist für uns vor ort mit
dem pkw ist kein durchkommen
thomas kraut ist 130 kilometer aus
baesweiler her gefahren um den menschen
in ophoven sein stromaggregat und eine
pumpe anzubieten
nun laden sie alles auf den traktor um
heute habe ich extra noch eine pumpe
gekauft weil die anderen nicht werde da
habe ich das stärkste modell da gekauft
dann gehst du hier heute hält 700
bewohner mussten raus aus ihren häusern
vergangenen nacht weil der nahegelegene
damm entlang des flüsschens ruhe nachgab
das ist umso bitterer als mann der
gemeinde noch letztes jahr vorgerechnet
hat dass sie keine dampfer stärkung
braucht
ich erwarte da auch von der
bezirksregierung man auch vom
wasserverband unterstützung dass man
eine nachberechnung vornimmt um dann die
hoffentlich wirklich ja erforderlichen
maßnahmen durchzuführen
das wäre eine erneuerung und
möglicherweise auch eben die ganze nacht
haben die helfer den kampf gegen die
wassermassen geführt mittlerweile hat
die bochumer feuerwehr die erschöpften
kollegen vor ort abgelöst und auch beim
sandsäcke voll schaufeln bekamen sie
unterstützung ein facebook aufruf hat
genügt und hunderte helfer aus der
region sind gekommen
das war ja schon fast eine schichtarbeit
hat sich lange hingezogen dass das land
immer wieder wechselte
es geht sehr viel wenn man will
und ich muss sagen was wir hier die tage
erlebt haben was die menschen hier auf
freiwillige was sie geschaffen haben
das hätten sie sehen müssen also es war
wahnsinn
es ist die solidarität und
hilfsbereitschaft die den opfern an
jetzt am meisten durch die krise hilft
sie kämpfen weiter gegen das wasser die
meisten todesopfer hat rheinland-pfalz
zu betrauern allein im raum ahrweiler
kamen nach derzeitigen stand für mehr
als 90 menschen jede hilfe zu spät
der landkreis liegt etwa zwischen bonn
und koblenz mit am schlimmsten ist die
lage in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler
auch hier muss gerade alles gleichzeitig
passieren retten bergen aufräumen und
das oft ohne funktionierendes strom oder
telefonnetz angela app hat berichtet im
ortsteil eiweiler haben die
aufräumarbeiten begonnen viele der
menschen verarbeiten dass er lebte in
dem sie jetzt einfach anpacken und
wieder ordnung in ihr leben bringen
aber hauptsache machen außer anpacken
fast 100 menschen verlieren in den
hochwasserfluten im kreis ahrweiler ihr
leben mehr als 670 sind verletzt
die zahlen werden so die polizei wohl
noch steigen glücklich die die es
überlebt haben
sie konnte ihre pflegebedürftige mutter
gerade noch vor dem wasser retten
wir sind einfach froh wir leben meine
mutter lebt und das ist es viele können
noch gar nicht fassen was passiert ist
waren noch im wohnzimmer gucken und dem
moment kam nur noch die flut die tür
aufgerissen
wir haben nur noch versucht nach oben
diese gruppe von 70 helfern ist aus ganz
deutschland zusammen bekommen michael
hofer linie die männer er ist
überwältigt von deren
einsatzbereitschaft
was hier passiert haben zweit im auto
gesessen und es war geweint vor glück
weil die leute so zu uns kam am
nürburgring werden hilfsgüter gesammelt
500 freiwillige helfer haben spenden für
hochwasseropfer zusammengetragen
bislang 120 lkw ladungen noch immer aber
werden viele menschen in der region
vermisst mit hilfe von hubschraubern
soll bis morgen abend nach weiteren
opfern gesucht werden anhand der
luftaufnahmen suchen die einsatzkräfte
systematisch die schwer zugänglichen
gebiete entlang der aa ab marion geiger
wir haben es gehört immer noch werden
menschen bei ihnen vermisst gestern
sprach der landkreis von 1.300 wie ist
diese zahl einzuordnen
ja diese erschreckend hohe zahl hat der
landkreis gestern kommuniziert und auch
heute noch gilt eine vielzahl von
menschen als vermisst
laut polizei koblenz ist allerdings die
genaue zahl sehr schwer zu beziffern und
die einsatzkräfte gehen auch davon aus
dass etliche dieser als vermisst
gemeldeten menschen in sicherheit sind
aber sich bisher einfach noch nicht
melden konnten
das liegt daran dass die mobilfunknetze
hier ungeheuer schlecht funktionieren
die infrastruktur ist zerstört alles
liegt in trümmern die menschen sind
geschockt und so ist die verständigung
sehr schwierig gleichwohl suchen die
rettungskräfte natürlich weiter nach
vermissten
dafür ist das gebiet mit hubschraubern
überflogen worden und in sektoren
eingeteilt und dort am boden suchen nun
die einsatzkräfte nach weiteren opfern
der flutkatastrophe auch in kellern die
bisher nicht zugänglich waren wird
gesucht und die einsatzleitung rechnet
damit dass sie weitere opfer finden
werden und angesichts dieser zerstörung
mit der das wasser hier über das land
gerauscht ist ist das leider auch sehr
wahrscheinlich
eindrücke aus ahrweiler dankeschön mario
geiger diese jahrhundertflut hat viele
todesopfer gefordert und sie hat
menschen in existenznot gebracht
betriebe und wohnhäuser zerstört
natürlich kann man sich gegen die
materiellen schäden durch erdrutsche und
hochwasser versichern aber im besonders
betroffenen rheinland pfalz zum beispiel
tun dass gerade mal 35 prozent der
hauseigentümer alexander pohl
das genaue ausmaß der flutkatastrophe
kann heute noch niemand wirklich
beziffern experten sprechen aber schon
jetzt von milliardenschäden und
klimatologen betonen überraschend kommt
all das nicht
die beobachtungen die wir aktuell machen
mit den schaden ereignissen in
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
passen in eine trendentwicklung hinein
die wir seitens munich re seit
jahrzehnten beobachten die häufigkeit
und intensität derartige unwetterschäden
hat bereits zugenommen in deutschland
das bislang schlimmste hochwasser im
jahr 2013 hat die versicherer rund vier
milliarden euro gekostet wahrscheinlich
ist dass diese summe im jahr 2021 noch
höher ausfällt viele betroffene stehen
vor dem ruin nur 45 prozent aller
privathäuser sind gegen schäden durch
hochwasser oder überschwemmung
abgesichert gewisse schäden habe ich
schon über die gebäudeversicherung und
auch über die hausratversicherung
versichert das ist zum beispiel der
sturm oder der hagel aber diese
zusätzlichen elementarschäden die
auftreten können wie hochwasser sturm
ehrt senkung erdrutsch sowas ist alles
über die elementarschadenversicherung
praktisch zusätzlich zu versichern
wer eine solche
elementarschadenversicherung
abgeschlossen aber sämtliche unterlagen
in den wassermassen verloren hat muss
sich keine sorgen machen betonen
branchenvertreter
selbstverständlich sind abgeschlossene
versicherung nach wie vor gültig da kann
man den leuten raten war zu überlegen
habe ich vielleicht beim ortsansässigen
versicherungsvertreter die versicherung
abgeschlossen da mal nachfragen oder
nicht ins internet vieles ist ja auch in
der cloud mit einer deutlichen erhöhung
der versicherungsbeiträge in folge der
flutkatastrophe sei vorerst nicht zu
rechnen
sie haben es fast in jedem beitrag
gesehen was tröstet im unglück ist die
große hilfsbereitschaft banken
fußballvereine bundestagsfraktionen
spenden
wenn auch sie helfen wollen das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat ein
spendenkonto eingerichtet stichwort zdf
hochwasser deutschland die iban lautet
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
190 auch in den überschwemmten orten
belgiens bangen die menschen um
vermisste angehörige das schicksal von
rund 20 personen ist ungewiss die zahl
der toten liegt inzwischen bei 24 helfer
aus frankreich italien und österreich
unterstützen die belgische feuerwehr wir
hier in einem stadtteil von lüttich im
besonders hart betroffenen per finster
gehirn die bewohner in ihren noch immer
überfluteten häuser zurück um ihr hab
und gut zu sichern
belgiens ministerpräsident rief für
kommenden dienstag einen nationalen
trauertag aus mehr zur unwetter
katastrophe erfahren sie in einem zdf
spezial direkt nach unserer sendung
jetzt zu coruna die zahlen steigen auch
hierzulande weiter das robert koch
institut meldet 1608 neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages das sind 6 165 mehr
als vergangenen samstag
außerdem kamen 22 todesfälle dazu die
sieben tage inzidenz stieg auf 9,4 in
den niederlanden liegt die inzidenz bei
über 400 nachdem vor drei wochen fast
alle beschränkungen aufgehoben worden
waren stieg die zahl der neuinfektionen
um das fünffache
zwar gibt es ängste dass die welle aus
dem nachbarland zu uns rüberschwappt am
regen grenzverkehr ändert das wenig noch
denn ab morgen sind die niederlande
wieder risikogebiet peter kunz
niederländisch als arbeit
sprache im deutschen krankenhaus in
nordhorn man arbeitet lebt und feiert
hier grenzüberschreitend und leidet
gemeinsam darunter dass die instanzen
auf beiden seiten der grünen grenze
gerade wieder steigen in den
niederlanden sogar durch die decke gehen
ein ansteckungsfälle lind recht disco
nächte ohne maske die neue freiheit in
den niederlanden seit ende juni hat
holland in not gebracht das
niederländische parlament unterbrach in
dieser woche die ferien und beschloss
wieder schärfere corona maßnahmen
reiserückkehrer aus dem risikogebiet
niederlande müssen in deutschland ab
morgen innerhalb von 48 stunden ein
negatives testergebnis vorlegen das
ungeregelte risiko bleibt der kleine
grenzverkehr schließung in den
niederlanden heißt unweigerlich die
jungen niederländer kommt zu uns und
kommt in unsere bars diskotheken und
naja im ergebnis wird wird das dazu
führen dass bei uns auch die
infektionszahlen nochmal steigen
ich hoffe dass es nicht überschwappt und
ich verfolgt dass die holländer auch
vielleicht alle mal denken okay es ist
nicht notwendig um die können sie über
zu gehen ich bleibe mal zu hause oder
ich bleibt man in holland 420 corona
kranke auch niederländer hat das grants
krankenhaus in nordhorn seit ausbruch
der pandemie versorgt mit einer bitter
nötigen atempause in den letzten wochen
die könnte vorbei sein
die angst vor corona varianten prägt
auch die islamische pilgerfahrt hadsch
die heute beginnt schon zum zweiten mal
hat saudi arabien die teilnehmerzahl
stark eingeschränkt statt sonst weit
mehr als zwei millionen gläubige aus
aller welt dürfen diesmal nur 60.000
einheimische nach mekka und sie müssen
geimpft sein
und jetzt formel 1 norbert da gab es
heute eine premiere ja in silverstone
beim großen preis von großbritannien
statt des üblichen quali vereins gab es
erstmals ein sprintrennen über 17 runden
kämpften die fahrer um die besten
startplätze in der poleposition morgen
wm-spitzenreiter max verstappen 100
kilometer attacke mit möglichst wenig
risiko dass die devise heute vor über
100.000 zuschauern max festakt im red
bull hier vorne links erwischt von platz
zwei aus ein super start überholt den
besten von gestern mercedes pilot lewis
hamilton
aber der siebenmalige weltmeister
versucht direkt zu kontern
ohne erfolg hamilton funk zwar an sein
team
ich gebe alles habt ihr noch power für
mich hat mercedes nicht verstappen holt
den sprintsieg drei wm-punkte und
startet morgen von der poleposition aus
ins rennen dahinter lewis hamilton und
sein team bot sebastian vettel wird
achter mit schumacher achtzehnter eklat
beim letzten testspiel der deutschen
olympia fußballer in japan kurz vor ende
der partie gegen honduras beim stand von
1 2 1 soll abwehrspieler jordan
torunarigha von hertha bsc von
gegenspielern mehrfach rassistisch
beleidigt worden sein
die mannschaft von dfb trainer stefan
kunz verließ daraufhin geschlossen das
spielfeld war für uns klar das verletzt
unsere werte
und dazu entschlossen die honduranische
mannschaft hat sich übrigens später beim
deutschen team entschuldigt
vorletzte etappe der tour de france
zuvor gab der deutsche radprofi andre
greipel bekannt ende des jahres seine
karriere zu beenden
tagessieger beim zeitfahren der belgier
bart van ark überschwänglich angetrieben
von seinen fans und der gesamtsieg der
ist auch entschieden der slowene tadej
hat heute sein gelbes trikot verteidigt
und wird nun als sieger der 100 achten
tour de france in paris durchs ziel
gehen und das 22-jährige radsport
wunderkind hat ja auch schon letztes
jahr die tour gewonnen
beeindruckende am alpenrand droht
dauerregen bis montagfrüh ansonsten wird
der sonntag weitgehend freundlich die
details und ausnahmen hat gleich katja
horneffer mehr zur flutkatastrophe sehen
sie jetzt gleich im zdf spezial und um
kurz vor elf im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
guten abend unser hauptaugenmerk liegt
auf rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen dort fällt morgen
kein regen an den alpen aber gibt es
stau niederschläge
da können durchaus 100 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammenkommen
auch an der nordsee werden die wolken
dichter bringen aber allenfalls etwas
nieselregen mit heute strahlte in der
nordwesthälfte die sonne
bei höchsttemperaturen von 24 bis 30
grad
25 grad bei uns an der donau unter
diesen dichteren wolken die auch
regenschauer und gewitter mit brachten
waren es 17 bis 23 grad in der nacht
sinken die werte auf 17 bis 11 grad und
in sachsen und in bayern gibt es zum
teil kräftige regenfälle zum teil mit
gewittern durchsetzt und am alpenrand
drohen also sturzbäche überschwemmungen
und erdrutsche
noch bis morgen vormittag sonst wird der
sonntag freundlich sonne und wolken
wechseln sich ab nur an der nordsee sind
die wolken etwas dichter und bringen ein
bisschen nieselregen netz der wind dazu
kommt aus nördlichen bis nordwestlichen
richtungen und so liegen die
höchsttemperaturen meist war 21 bis 26
am oberrhein bei 28 grad
die neue woche startet sehr freundlich
guten abend